son ex-femme est sud-américaine tu
n'imagines même pas les messages que tu
vas recevoir sur les réseaux sociaux de
la part de ces femmes
pour dire la vérité
j'en ai rien à faire
vraiment rien parce que je les connais
même pas
ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas de vie
ils sont là
quelle importance je suis censé leur
donner aucune on ne se rencontrera
jamais
ils sont comme des robots je les
considère comme je sais pas alors
l'attaque est quand même un peu un peu
basse honteuse on est d'accord
c'est la taxe
américaine d'ailleurs elle a fait elle a
fait un tweet elle a répondu
il arrive
technique
drapeau
d'américaine voilà c'était curieux de la
part de leur appliquer quand même mais
c'est honteux ce qu'il a fait
c'est-à-dire s'attaquer aux origines des
gens c'est infâme alors qu'il venait de
trouver un accord c'est une femme
pas mal pas mal oui donc c'est infâme il
venait de trouver un accord pour la
garde des enfants elle repart à Miami
donc je pense que lui il est dégoûté de
ça ou en tout cas parce que c'est vrai
qu'il soit il sera éloigné des enfants
sans doute mais l'attaquer là-dessus
c'est vraiment dégueulasse quoi c'est le
cas déclaré la guerre
je parle en tant qu'expert il a quand
même décodé le premier il avait mis une
nana chez lui
on est rendu compte que la meuf elle
avait mis derrière mais non elle avait
mangé des confitures et comme et comme
lui mange pas de sucre parce que c'est
un sportif elle en a déduit que
quelqu'un aille manger de la confiture
donc qu'une meuf était venue oui mais
d'ailleurs c'était la baby-sitter elle
l'a Shakira l'appelait Mosquita muerta
ça veut dire sainte-nitouche elle se
doute
le moustique
elle est super jolie
c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
je passe l'aspirateur
je lance un casting pour
pour la maison non c'est sa femme
imaginez que je cherche mes visiteurs si
cette personne rentre chez moi ma femme
elle a dehors mais elle est même
pas engagée vous êtes viré à jamais
alors Gérard Piqué il avait quand même
dit ouvre la confiance qu'elle vous
porte quand même
voilà vous avez vu qu'il avait quand
même dit elle avait dit de lui qu'il
était passé d'une Ferrari voilà donc il
avait répondu on dirait qu'il avait fait
il avait fait une photo il était à côté
d'une Twingo voilà et c'est très bien
contrat avec Casio parce qu'elle avait
dit tu as quitté les relais exactement
avec Casio c'est vrai
alors moi je suis en 19 je suis passé de
Rolex à quartier
ça vous intéresse
on va citer soit évidemment et flic
flacon et voilà et voilà moi je trouve
que c'est un goujat il est l'incarnation
type du type d'homme que je déteste et
que je méprise non mais j'en ai eu un et
similitude avec le fait de tromper sa
femme être bafoué être et de s'afficher
avec la nouvelle gonzesse sur les
réseaux sociaux et après le mec ne
comprend pas pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a
des choses qui se disent et pourquoi
est-ce que elle réplique et que elle
fait un texte long comme ça pour dire
qu'elle a été trahie etc
ils avaient fait un contrat devant un
avocat en disant voilà il sait pas en
bon terme pour la garde des enfants
il devait pas s'afficher avec quelqu'un
d'autre et lui il a rompu le pacte
pendant un an il devait pas s'afficher
avec quelqu'un d'autre à accepter pour
respecter mais oui d'accord mais ça
c'était digérer
aussi la métropole aussi c'est qu'il
insulte quand même les origines de cette
femme et donc les origines de ses
enfants et donc c'est vraiment des
produits qui est un peu dingue elle a
peu dingue elle arrête pas de se
ridicule
américaine elles sont un peu dingues
représentez sa mère qui avait fait un
contrat comme ça c'était Michael Douglas
avec Catherine Zeta-Jones et en fait il
avait prévu que si jamais il était un
peu il était un peu chaud
donc il a fait il avait fait un contrat
si jamais il était pris la main dans le
sac pour pas dire autre chose
ça lui coûtait genre 100 millions de
dollars ah oui il a pas bougé